we are doing it have Hans Neiman with us
here in the studio after his victory
against eroshan Hans first of all
congratulations uh important victory for
you would you say that yeah very
important like today I realized I
decided you know either I'm going to
lose I'm going to win there's no there's
no in between and that's exactly what it
felt like from for us as well the
commentators you were putting a lot of
pressure on your opponent's time was
that the case was that the strategy
going into into the game
well um
I just didn't feel like thinking at all
and yeah I definitely wanted to put some
pressure and considering I think
whenever someone is having a difficult
tournament you have to
even he held himself very well under the
pressure but uh eventually he cracked
but uh okay I was not in the mood for
another Berlin game today let's just put
it that way it was definitely a very
tense middle game I have to say uh take
us through the yeah we've been saying so
let's first after Knight D7 all the way
he's curious Bishop like Bishop B3 just
stopped this entire plan like if H6
Bishop H4 and G5 Bishop g395 that's 95.
oops yes okay Queen A5 apparently
there's green a flat yeah I don't know
okay but it's just funny that there's
actually okay it's still okay I was
let's say I'm not considering but yeah
this was the what I I mean yeah okay and
I just saw an ig5 and I stopped yeah
then to go beyond that but anyways um
yeah so now this is actually really
quite nice but again I played the king's
Indian and he goes Bishop G5 and he had
he played let's go before he I think
before he plays Bishop G5 on the the
third move
uh so here instead of C4 he's probably
Bishop Bishop G5 before but that'll be
honest I did not
uh prepare uh I did not take the
preparation too seriously so maybe he's
also played this but I was hoping he
would go for something because if you
can if they play this against the king's
Indian no I played the keys in every
game if I can get this you know it's
like such a fight and and we were
discussing about that as the tournament
drags on the energy levels are much more
important rather than just prepare for
like five hours before the game yeah to
be honest um I did not uh even check a
single single variation in the king's
Indian
but um I had already decided that I was
just going to you know freestyle a bit
because um you know I felt like I need
to go back to my roots of playing just
absolutely psychotic uh chess
um because I I I I don't know what's
gotten into me you know playing the
Berlin and and trying to make draws you
know I've always you know become a bit
too professional
um but I felt like if any day was the
day to go absolutely insane
and disregard you know all chess
principles then today was the day and it
paid off uh it did but let's yeah so so
of course when I get you know this was
the first year so this is of course
amazing yes this is like a dream yeah
and okay he's and then A5 okay let's
first A5 this is an inaccuracy because
again
uh you're never going to okay in my
opinion if you're ever going to punish
my let's say specular display you have
to Castle Queen side like Queens like if
you're going to if something's going to
happen it's going to happen to exploit
the king side weaknesses so A5 for me is
just weird because first of all okay
after A5 you know the Rook is sort of
stuck to the pawn and also this beef the
beef is like the the beat break is
coming so it just didn't make much sense
to me uh okay you should note that B5 is
sort of a threat
um so like yeah it's sort of a threat
because
um I can't even think of like a passing
movie a rook A3 is I guess stopping it
but what if you go Castle then you don't
have the Rook on the issue Yeah Yeah but
I for example right now B5 would be an
idea because if you know take B3 yeah
that's like the worst movie I could
think of but but basically the point is
that after a b a b your forces are going
to eight and then you the d85.4 so B5 is
sort of a threat so I can understand why
you played A5 but just from a positional
perspective I was like okay it's just
game over like like in this position I'm
thinking okay like
life is good I'm gonna Cruise you know
and I was cruising let's go to the next
critical Moment Like sure I was so happy
Knight G4 you know F5 you know 95 to you
know and then and then Queen E5 was so
happy with this tick tick you know pitch
five Bishop G6 Take Your Heroes okay
game is over I I was like this is just
lost and I okay of course it's
extremists back in love and I see it's
equal but I'm just thinking like you
know I've got the B6 break coming I've
got Bishop on D4 I've got G4 H5
of course my optimism uh is a bit uh
unfounded as usual but I just disagree
with the computer here to be honest I I
complete this okay so yeah so Rick have
seven more practical perspectives yeah
yeah I look at this position I'm like I
don't believe it's equal but let's go
back so I thought maybe what if I play
Rook of Queen Egypt five
uh this was maybe uh and here's where G4
okay so uh okay uh because when I was
playing Rook F7 and then he plays 1984
it's like oh wait 1965 is right
um but okay Bishop D4 yeah Rook E3 okay
so everything like yeah so okay G4 Rook
G3 yeah so okay yeah this is just
ridiculous why not just the B5 like this
whole Rook F4 because I thought like I
just miscalculated like when I play Rook
F5 okay because here okay let's say just
not rectify like you just look at the
structure yes like I've got this is just
a dream like come on this is just game
over like like let's say you play B5
yeah let's say I play b56 and you go
like Rook D2 like come on this is just
disgusting like uh this whole structure
you've got pressure everywhere H5 I
should just I should have I just had
zero patience
um and this is very stupid you know I
again this is just a disgusting position
but I play Rook of five just a way too
uh way too arrogant and uh completely
underestimate this and then now I'm like
sitting here and I'm like wait you know
this is uh this is not too pretty yeah
yeah so
I guess Rick F5 is just uh
completely just yeah I missed I just
missed everything yeah I thought you
know he's going low on time just going
to collapse you know uh game over and
then he does this and I'm like uh yeah
okay that is bursting my potatoes
yeah oh Queen D1 okay that's ridiculous
yeah so here again to A7 did you
calculate this whole H4 E5 at the end of
it well I was like or was that
I was more looking at his clock and uh
trying to play the move H4 at all costs
you know because what else am I going to
do in this position am I going to sit
there and like pretend like I'm okay or
like I understood that the only way that
I do not like lose is to play H4 so if
it's not like well let's just say that
um I I had I was taking a very
psychological approach here and then
when he played Queen A7 I'm like okay
you know it's I I already knew he was
going to lose like I could already when
I was 27 I know the game was over
because because it's like the you know
this you know if you look at the
momentum had completely shifted right
like you know in the opening I do this
weird stuff I play quickly I take
control and then I have all the moments
and then I make one just idiotic move
and he plays like three genius moves and
I'm sitting there like an idiot and then
here okay he plays a queen Ace uh yeah
and I'm yeah okay so he still could have
had Queen theater I saw this um
but but
and then Eric H6 yeah okay I also
considered um instead of this I could go
Rook f8 yeah Queen E6 Queen F7 yeah but
here he I yeah now he can take I thought
if he can take first and then King takes
after you Rook say it's still not easy
um
yeah it's probably fine but like Rook C1
Rook C5 I wasn't sure how to evaluate
this but the considering my previous
position I was you were happy I was very
happy I was very happy um uh but then
like yeah okay this E5 Ampersand is like
it's just it's a very interesting
concept because uh like this you never
think this Pawn is going to move but the
queen is sort of uh it's a very nice
concept probably the only way I could
have won this but I guess you know when
you're an arrogant idiot you get
rewarded sometimes
um uh to all the people who think I'm
not humble I am a complete idiot and uh
I have a lot to learn in chess and uh I
have too many things to work on uh and
I'm yeah what are you going to work
during the rest day
no more berlins
that's not even about working on the
Russia it's just it's going to the rest
day and somehow
um convincing myself not to just finish
the next game with an hour and a half
you know it's like uh no no I just rest
day you know
try to go to the pool like at a time
we'll know what we'll expect
um
Paparazzi yes you're expecting that or I
have a question what was that well I I
haven't been going to the pool March
after that I don't really I don't really
enjoy that but no no okay it's the rest
day and uh I think I think a comeback is
brewing because now I have two more
whites and I'm playing uh Linderman and
Liang to the lower seeds so I could feel
a a comeback uh I think I think a
comeback is certainly coming and I've
definitely been humbled a lot in these
past in this tournament so I think it's
always good when someone is arrogant as
me is humbled
how does it feel to be a professional
chess player these days I ask also this
question Jeffrey but I wonder would you
recommend to the others to become
professional chess players these days
well
you think I'm a professional chess
player I don't know I'm asking you and
if you consider yourself I think as a
professional well you know
um I think
advice how to become a professional
chess player or how to survive
you know it's sucking your soul mm-hmm
sorry I didn't hear you yeah I mean what
are advantages and disadvantages you
live this life of professional employers
say that the life is not it's definitely
not for everyone and um I think a lot of
people you know end up
I think it's it's an extremely difficult
life
um unless you make it so I think it's
it's very similar to sort of
um some music or or something you know
where you really really have to
um have a very very um High pain and
stress tolerance
and you have to be able to have this um
ultimate confidence in yourself uh that
no matter what you will achieve for
example right now you know it would be
very easy for me to be very discouraged
by my career
um and by uh what is happening but uh I
I sort of have this and I've always had
this
um faith and confidence in myself which
has allowed me to to persevere uh
through very difficult moments in my
chest career because to be honest there
are like probably four different
Junctions where I could have quit chess
forever so
um thankfully I I made it I made it
through those but I think that's a
perfect dress player
you know I wouldn't recommend it to
everyone unless you're you know unless
you
really really believe in yourself or you
have the proper supports
um you know if you've got uh
certain countries like Switzerland you
know giving you a kilo of gold when you
become a grand master and maybe it's
okay maybe but uh
it's not something for the lighthearted
I'll say that yeah and you see a lot of
people struggle to break through and
then go and do you know stuff like
commentating and podcasting
so you know I feel attacked that's okay
it just isn't for everyone and you know
um you were a streamer yourself come on
were or are you are
I cannot tell you last time I streamed
so I definitely wouldn't say I am a
streamer yeah I'm a competitive chess
player on the path to becoming world
champion that's how I would put my
LinkedIn profile
this is your first U.S Championship
you've got 10 Rounds under your belt
what uh have you learned thus far I've
learned a lot this has actually been a
very introspective time in my life okay
and um I've learned a lot and I think
that um I I'm really looking forward to
um to working on my game and and taking
all of the lessons
um that I've learned on and off uh the
the chessboard because this has been a
very unique time and uh I think the
tournament um
oh of course it hasn't gone well but you
know when you're losing games there's
always a lot to learn from them
so in a specific regard I would say that
the
I would not like to share what
weaknesses I've discovered in my own
game but uh I'm really looking forward
to to just improving and continuing
my journey as a chess player well good
luck on your journey and good luck in
the last three rounds enjoy your your
free day Hans thank you